thailand's our ancient gigantic
creatures that are studied by the
organization known as Moana while Moana
initially designates any such creatures
it finds as massive unidentified
terrestrial organisms but once they are
formally identified they are now
classified as tyrants but what do these
Titans eat
Godzilla himself doesn't he he feeds on
radiation his species on the other hand
is most likely omnivorous as Godzilla
janilla fed on plants and meat when he
was young and when he grew to be a
sub-adult
he even ate whales Godzilla absorbs
nuclear energy and doesn't eat in the
same sense as most animals do the theory
makes sense given that he was created
and gained his famous abilities from
nuclear tests which was a major plot
point in a 1954 original 1984 return of
Godzilla was the first true instance in
which we see Godzilla feeding off
radiation as he attacked a nuclear power
plant and used its reactor to provide
sustenance for his well-being this idea
was also repeated in Godzilla 2000 and
Godzilla vs. megaguirus it has been
explained before in fan pages that his
stomach has been transformed or it has
evolved into a plasma organ which stores
and emits powerful radiation in the form
of his atomic breath and if the amount
of radiation exceeds certain limits he
goes into a meltdown like most nuclear
power plants do this brings us to the
topic of how Godzilla feeds on radiation
the way he absorbs radiation is unsure
but we can speculate that since he is a
mutated version of a previously unknown
reptile his skin and whole body for that
matter is evolved to detect and absorb
radiation storing it in his evolved
stomach are also his dose of blades
which acts like batteries so to say that
Godzilla is an alpha predator is both
wrong and right for the different
reasons as a sub adult Godzilla feeds on
whales and other kaiju presumably and
there is nothing in this planet that can
challenge his status except for the mera
prime and most a zero therefore he is an
unchallengeable predator stalking the
planet's oceans another point of
discussion is that since Godzilla feeds
and radiation he must continuously
traverse the oceans to locate pockets of
geothermal radiation
to quench his hunger and since other
titans also share his same food source
there is extensive competition for this
resource his primal instincts to feed
and survive may as well be the crux of
his evolution into an alpha species that
control and check the balance of muta
populations and other titans as they
might prove a trap to him losing his
radiation sources now let's dive a
little deeper into the cellular level of
Godzilla it has been said that a muta
prime can detect radiation in a Titans
blood and lay her eggs there for the
hatchlings to feed on when they come out
and a Titans death so talents have
radioactive blood and this is due to
them having a high concentration of
uranium in their system
Godzilla species also shares the same
characteristic their blood is really
active and the radiation in it is the
primary source of energy for the Titan
so in the way the uranium or other
radioactive elements in a Titans blood
is equivalent to carbohydrates and fats
for normal animals we can also imply
that the Titans DNA is extremely tough
as to deter unwanted mutations which
might cause death or cancer in the
creatures organs but there is another
factor to include and this comes down to
the nutritional requirement of any
animal to replace cells an organic
material which would mean that a Titan
has to eat other animals and Titans to
gain material for bodybuilding this
would mean that Godzilla and the other
Titans either lose so little of their
organic makeup over millions of years or
they synthesize their own proteins like
plants and certain fungi if not that it
means that they do occasionally attack
and feed on other animals and other
Titans
which would in turn explain the
extremely low population of Titans in
this planet so I hope you enjoyed this
ran on Godzilla's favorite food unlike
the Tristar Zillah which feeds on fish
most of us teases the geothermal
radiation and other Titans as food
sources anyway do hit us with your
thoughts on the matter and do like share
and subscribe